the Joe Rogan experience what is the
status of Adonis Stevenson is did he
recover
yeah he's recovered Z okay now I mean
he's not his former self but he's
certainly like I think living a good
life ease because I know that was like
that was one of the more recent like
superstar guys right I'll never forget
brain injury survivor come to those
injuries but it's life-changing like
this guy's gonna never be the Adonis
Stevenson he was before the fight he's
always going to know the rest of his
life deal with those injuries and have
challenges in a way that result of
thought of you Shenzhen is there videos
of him I've seen about it or anything
yeah I mean I haven't seen him talk
about it in depth but we've seen him
like his motor skills are coming back he
smile and he's able to like speak so
it's not like Jeremy Cleland no no that
the general mcclellan fight it's
interesting it kind of in many ways
changed Roy Jones jr. his thoughts on
the sport you know and that he never
wanted her to turn out like that but
then Roy gets older and he's still
fighting fighting fighting people like
deep into his forties right and you're
like this is crazy like this is the same
guy that after Jill McClung got hurt
said he would never want to go out like
that and he's fighting like young
badasses in Russia and [ __ ] but you
still think you can do it yeah it's hard
to stop doing it like and it's easy for
me to say hey man that was your last
fight like let's let's take it easy
I look at Bernard right he's the best
example right into his 50s right but he
had a style that was crafty enough to
have some longevity in it without taking
that kind of damage like Roy embarrass
you and but he's still there in front of
you which is what's the embarrassing
part so if your motor skills slow down
if your reflexes slow down you're gonna
get hit yeah yeah a knockdown you [ __ ]
up yeah but what he told me in an
interview and might be one of them one
of those moments when I was talking to a
guy he said something that was like I
thought I should have known until I
heard it and there was at home I can't
believe I didn't realize that he said
it's not the fight
that destroy you it's the gym that
destroys you it's the sparring oh yeah
those are the rounds that destroy
fighters oh yeah and it's like the
hundreds and hundreds of rounds -
thousands of rounds that you're fighting
that nobody sees that you're not getting
paid for you're taking that punishment
headgear or not that's what you're
seeing at the end of a fighter's career
do you remember was it Danny Jacobs jr.
who was it that someone know something
that wasn't him
no it wasn't Danny Jacobs it was someone
else someone that said that they stopped
sparring oh yeah well he's fighting
covilhã and that was Anthony yard that's
right
that's right right that's it he stops
boy he's a never spot yeah yeah and no
one believes it but yeah and then anyone
who does is like we prize it up it's
fine yeah he looked great in moments in
that fight like it was like the eighth
round where he had Kovalev and deep [ __ ]
yeah man that was a crazy thing like his
philosophy if I remember correctly was
yards philosophy was if you don't get
hit at all in training you will be so
much fresher when you get to the ring so
he was doing just ridiculous MIT work
and bag work and drills and he already
knew how to box so his idea was that he
will have some sort of advance and he
was a really fairly green guy right in
terms of like world-class competition
this is the very first really big fight
yeah but really physically talented and
just built like a brick [ __ ] and
still is all those things yes but I
think the rub is that ya do have to spar
right you know you have to feel shots
that no trainer that I've ever had this
discussion with and right after the
fight plenty of people wanted to talk
about it anybody be like yeah that made
sense no it's just part of it you find
that a little bit in MMA no Donald
Cerrone was doing that for a while he
wasn't sparring at all I was just doing
pad work and just doing wrestling drills
and stuff like that kickboxing drills
yeah listen if pad work and like a
really good workout could make your
world champion I'd be like three
I'm world champion right now it's not it
sparring is a reality check
yeah yeah you know I mean you need to
need it otherwise you're just like doing
aerobics yeah you need to be tuned in to
movement to people and also to danger to
be able to exist and to be able to fire
under pressure you have to hit you have
to take shots you have to absorb those
try keep your eyes open like this like
all of these things you can't you can't
download them yeah you can't simulate
them but you can only do that so many
times that's the other thing it's like
there's only so many times you could
survive it you know and gym wars are
real they take a toll on people yeah
yeah I wish that we could shoot that
show still because you wouldn't let you
they won't know everybody hide things
now yeah everybody thinks that they guys
Dory's right a secret yeah like there's
a story that uh Klitschko knocked out
Deonte and training like someone Dillon
while I was talking about that recently
mm-hmm you know and I don't make much of
that because I think it's unfair I am
one of these guys like yeah what happens
in the gym stays here I'm in there with
a camera it's a setup thing well then
okay we know what's going on right but
the point of spawn is that you're
working on [ __ ] right you're trying
things you're like you know you have
weaknesses you're gonna like lean on
trying news you know opening up your
game you're opening up and you're
trusting the guy that you're sparring
with to help you work on those things
and like catch you if you slip it yeah
so then if the guy catches you and
you're slippin then a month later a year
I caught that [ __ ] slipper so
yeah I was paying you to do mainly we
talked about I flew you in so I try not
to make much of that
[Applause]